We're now going to study the
unit circle a little bit more,
and see how it extends, I guess
we could say, the traditional
SOH-CAH-TOA definitions
of functions.
And how we can actually use it
to solve for angles that the
SOH-CAH-TOA definition of the
trig functions actually
doesn't help us with.
So let's just, as a
review, remember what
SOH-CAH-TOA told us.
I'll write it up here
in this corner.
I don't want to get confusing,
because I don't want to
write over too much.
SOH, CAH, TOA.
I'm sorry.
I got it all jumbled up here.
That told us that if we have a
right angle that the sine of an
angle in the right angle is
equal to the opposite side
over the hypotenuse.
The cosine of an angle is
equal to the adjacent
side over hypotenuse.
And the tangent side is
equal to the opposite
over the adjacent side.
And this worked fine for us.
But if you think about it,
what happens when that angle
approaches 90 degrees?
Because you can't have two 90
degree angles in a right angle.
Or what happens when that angle
is greater than 90 degrees?
Or what if it went negative?
And that's why, if you remember
from the previous video,
we needed the unit
circle definition.
So let's review the unit
Let me erase this.
Dum di-dum di-dum.
I actually got this unit
circle-- I think I got
it from Wikipedia.
But I want to give due
credit to whoever I did
it get for, this drawing
of the unit circle.
But the unit circle
kind of extends that
SOH-CAH-TOA definition.
It tells us if we have a unit
circle-- and this is a picture
of a unit circle here-- a unit
circle is just a circle
centered at the origin,
centered at the point 0, 0,
and it has a radius of 1.
So it intersects the x-axis
at 1, 0 and negative 1, 0.
It intersects the y-axis at
0, 1 and 0, negative 1.
If we have a unit circle we
define-- let's start with the
cosine of theta-- we define the
cosine of theta as let's take
an angle that's between two
radiuses in this unit circle.
And one radius is going to
be the positive x-axis
between 0 and 1.
So one radius is going
to be this line here.
And then we have the angle is
the angle between you can kind
of view that as the base
radius and some other radius.
So let's say this
case right here.
And this would be our angle.
The unit circle definition
tells us that the cosine of
this angle is equal to the
x-coordinate where this radius
intersects the unit circle, and
that the sine of this function
is equal to the y-coordinate
where this point intersects
the unit circle.
So for example, in this case--
if you can read behind
my line-- this says 30
degrees equals pi/6.
So this angle right here is
30 degrees, or pi/6 radians.
And what this definition tells
us is that the sine of 30
degrees is 1/2, and that the
cosine of 30 degrees is
square root of 3/2.
And what I want to show you is
that this unit circle
definition actually coincides
with our SOH-CAH-TOA
definition, but then
it extends it.
So let's see how we can get
from that SOH-CAH-TOA
definition to this unit circle
definition, and why they're
actually consistent
with each other.
So let me erase some of
what I have written here.
Let me get the eraser tool.
I'm going to erase what I had.
So let me go back to the pen
tool, make it small again.
OK.
I think I'm all set.
So let's go back to that theta.
Let's say that this
is the theta.
And as we said, this angle
is 30 degrees or pi/6.
Let's drop a line from
that point to the x-axis.
And as we see this line is
perpendicular, so this
is a 90 degree angle.
And if this is a 30 degree
angle here-- this is 30.
Right?
Theta equals 30.
This is 30, this is 90.
What is this angle?
Well, this is a 60 degree
angle, because they
add up to 180.
So this is a 30-60-90 triangle.
Interesting.
And what do you remember
about 30-60-90 triangles?
Well, the side opposite the
30 degree side is 1/2 the
length of the hypotenuse.
I hope you remember that.
I don't want to
confuse you too much.
So this is the side opposite
the 30 degree side.
Right?
And what's the hypotenuse?
This is the hypotenuse.
And what's the length
of this hypotenuse?
Well it's 1, because this is a
unit circle and this is the
radius of the unit circle.
So the length of this
hypotenuse is 1, and so the
length of this side, which
is opposite the 30 degree
angle, is going to be 1/2.
Right?
And I'm just using the
30-60-90 triangles that we've
done previous videos on.
And what's the side opposite
the 60 degree side?
Well once again it's
square root of 3/2
times the hypotenuse.
And so it's square root of 3/2.
Right?
So we can figure out that this
side is square root of 3/2,
and that this side is 1/2.
So a couple of things
we can figure out.
Just by looking at this we can
immediately say, well what's
the coordinate of this point?
Well it's x-coordinate
is right here.
Right?
It's x-coordinate would
be square root of 3/2.
That's this right here.
This distance.
And it's y-coordinate would be
the length of this side of
the right triangle, or 1/2.
And there we have
it right here.
It was already written for us.
The x-coordinate is the
square root of 3/2 and
the y-coordinate is 1/2.
And now what I want to show you
is why this x-coordinate can be
taken as the cosine of theta,
and why this y-coordinate can
be taken as the sine of theta.
Well what does
SOH-CAH-TOA tell us?
Well let's start
with the cosine.
So SOH, CAH, TOA.
So CAH.
Cosine is adjacent over
hypotenuse, right?
Well, in this triangle I just
drew, what is the adjacent
side to this angle?
Right?
Because we're trying to figure
out the cosine of this
angle, this 30 degrees.
Well the adjacent side to this
angle is, of course, this side.
Right?
So adjacent is
square root of 3/2.
We figured that out just now.
And what's the hypotenuse?
Well the hypotenuse is this
side, which has length 1
because it was the unit circle
and that's the radius of it.
So the cosine of this angle
using the SOH-CAH-TOA
definition is square root
of 3-- the adjacent side--
over the hypotenuse 1.
So square root of 3/2 over
1, which is the square root
of 3/2, which was the same
thing as the x-coordinate.
Similarly, we can look at SOH.
Sine equals opposite
over hypotenuse.
Well what's the opposite side?
It's 1/2.
And the hypotenuse is 1 here.
So the sine is just 1/2 over 1.
And so we have it here.
So that's why the unit circle
definition isn't kind of a
replacing definition for the
SOH-CAH-TOA definition, it's
really just an extension that
allows us-- I mean, for 30
degrees SOH-CAH-TOA worked, for
45 degrees SOH-CAH-TOA worked,
for 60 degrees it would work.
But once you get to 90 it
becomes a little bit more
difficult if you use
traditional SOH-CAH-TOA and you
try to draw a right triangle
that has two 90 degree angles
in it-- because you couldn't.
And especially once you get to
angles that are larger than 90
or angles that actually
could even go negative.
It's not drawn here in the unit
circle, but 330 degrees is the
same thing as negative 30
degrees, because you could go
either way in the circle.
And you could keep going
around the circle.
You could figure out the sine
or the cosine of, you know, 1
million degrees if you just
keep going around the circle.
So hopefully this gives you
a sense of the unit circle
definition of the sine
and cosine functions.
And, of course, the tangent
function is always just the
sine over the cosine,
or the y over the x.
And you could use the
unit circle definition
for that as well.
And I'll leave it for you as an
exercise to try to derive all
of these other values using
this unit circle, and using
what you already know about
30-60-90 triangles and what you
already know about 45-45-90
triangles, or what you
already know about the
Pythagorean theorem.
And you should be able to
figure out all of these values
going around the unit circle.
Hopefully that was helpful.
See you soon.